So, filtering patterns all have one thing in
common. They don't change the actual records of our
data. So by that I mean, if we have some long list of data with lots and
lots of records. One, two, three, so on.
A filtering pattern will, go through the entire data
set and just. Decide which data to keep, and
which to throw away. And so if this giant
list is the input this smaller list, this
subset of the original data would be the
output. And there's a lot of ways filtering
can happen. We can have a simple filter, which
is basically just a function which returns keep
or throw away for. Each of these records, and
for the records that get kept. Well, they
wind up in the output. There's a bloom filter,
which we're actually not going to talk much about, but
it's worth knowing about, because this is a much more
efficient probabilistic filter. That comes with some trade-offs and you
should check out the instructor notes if you want to read
more. We also have things like sampling. Which is just
a way to make a smaller data set from a
large data set. By pulling out some sample, maybe the
highest values of a particular field. If we want to pull
out a representative sample, one that we think matches the characteristics
of the original data. We can use random sampling. And finally, we can
use this idea of filtering to find the, I don't know, top
ten of something, and that's an exercise we're actually going to do. Click.